OK, this thing happened last month at our radio show, where, I'm sure you remember the rally of white nationalists and offshoots of the alt-right who descended into a kind of white haze on Charlottesville, marched with torches, one woman was killed. The president spoke about it several times. Anyway, when that story first broke here at our show, we realized that the guy who organized that rally in Charlottesville, Jason Kessler, was a member of this right wing men's group that one of our producers, Zoe Chace, had been following for months, like, since the winter.
好的，这件事发生在上个月我们的广播节目中，我相信你们还记得那场由白人民族主义者和“另类右翼”分支组成的集会。他们像一阵白色的迷雾笼罩了夏洛茨维尔，举着火把游行，造成一名女性死亡。总统对此发表过几次讲话。总之，当这个故事第一次出现在我们的节目中时，我们意识到夏洛茨维尔集会的组织者杰森·凯斯勒（Jason Kessler）是一个右翼男性组织的成员，我们的制作人佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）已经跟踪该组织好几个月了，从冬天就开始了。
The group has since disavowed Kessler. This was a group founded on the premise that they are not racist. The group's leader denounced the rally. But it's confusing, right? Like, all these groups that you hear about these days, like the groups at Charlottesville. All these little groups that stand for slightly different things in this movement that's shifting, and slippery, and hard to get a grasp on. And often the things their leaders say in public seem like a whitewash, if you'll pardon the expression, of what they really believe. Not that the leader of this particular group necessarily was whitewashing anything.
该组织此后已经声明与凯斯勒撇清关系。这是一个建立在“他们不是种族主义者”这一前提下的团体。该组织的领导人谴责了那次集会。但这让人感到困惑，对吧？就像你最近听说的所有这些团体，比如夏洛茨维尔的那些团体。这些小组织在这一运动中主张略有不同的东西，而这个运动正在转变，变得难以捉摸。通常他们的领导人在公开场合所说的话，如果请原谅我使用这个表达的话，似乎是在粉饰他们真正的信仰。并不是说这个特定团体的领导人一定在粉饰什么。
Anyway, today we have the story of a guy who stumbled upon that group that Zoe was following and got involved with them. And this is, like, long before Charlottesville, long before Trump was president. And this guy is not exactly who you'd expect would end up with a group like this. He's a liberal black guy, a relationship expert, and a comedian named Dante Nero. He makes part of his living giving advice to guys on how to pick up women, like this. This is from a podcast.
总之，今天我们要讲一个偶然发现佐伊跟踪的那个组织并卷入其中的人的故事。这还是在夏洛茨维尔集会很久之前，在特朗普当选总统很久之前。而这个人并不是你所期望会加入这种组织的人。他是一个自由派黑人，一位关系专家，也是一名喜剧演员，名叫但丁·尼禄（Dante Nero）。他的一部分收入来源是向男人们提供关于如何搭讪女性的建议，就像这样。这是来自播客的内容。
Ask me to consult you, the first thing I would tell you to do is, I do this thing where I go lay five bricks a day. I tell a guy to speak to five women every day. They don't have to be pretty. They don't have to be somebody you wanna [BLEEP]. But you just say "beautiful eyes," "oh, I like your glasses," "your makeup is impeccable." So five a day every day for eight weeks. That's 285 women. Look, you learn things about that interaction between men and women. And--
让我为你提供咨询，我告诉你的第一件事就是，我每天会去码五块砖。我告诉一个人每天要和五个女人说话。她们不必长得漂亮。她们不必是你想要发生关系的女性。你只需要说“漂亮的眼睛”、“哦，我喜欢你的眼镜”、“你的妆容无可挑剔”。所以，每天五个，持续八周。那就是285个女人。你看，你会从这种男女互动中学到东西。而且——
Dante Nero became the spiritual leader of sorts for this right wing group that Zoe was following. He was drinking with the guys. He was giving them pointers about women. And he saw the group's evolution, and he was really surprised when a couple of the guys in the group ended up in Charlottesville. Surprised and disturbed. Well, today on our program, the fuzzy boundaries between these right wing groups and how guys who do not think of themselves as racist end up sharing opinions, and hanging out with guys who definitely are. Where does that lead?
但丁·尼禄成为了佐伊所跟踪的那个右翼组织的精神领袖。他和那些人一起喝酒。他给他们提供关于女性的建议。他见证了这个组织的发展，当组织里的几个人最终出现在夏洛茨维尔时，他真的感到非常惊讶。既惊讶又不安。好吧，今天在我们的节目中，我们将讨论这些右翼组织之间模糊的界限，以及那些并不认为自己是种族主义者的人，最终如何与那些明确是种族主义者的人分享观点并混在一起。这会通向哪里呢？
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And let's just jump right into Act One.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。让我们直接进入第一幕。
Act One, Lost in the Proud. Quick warning before we start. There's some strong language in this story. Nothing graphic, but some slurs, and men referring to the existence of sex. Or, actually, to the nonexistence of it. Here's Zoe. Her story about Dante Nero starts earlier this year.
第一幕，迷失在“骄傲”中。在开始之前先做一个简短的警告。这个故事中包含一些粗俗的语言。没有什么带有描述性的，但包含一些种族歧视用语，以及男人谈论性的存在。或者，实际上，谈论它的不存在。这是佐伊的报道。她关于但丁·尼禄的故事开始于今年早些时候。
I only met Dante after months of hanging out with these guys, these new right, alt-right, alt-light Twitter trolls. I started meeting up with them right after Trump's inauguration. Even though their guy won, they were still acting like insurgents, not like winners. Like their revolution wasn't over yet.
我在和这些家伙——这些新右翼、另类右翼、另类轻量级推特喷子混了几个月后才见到但丁。特朗普就职典礼后，我刚开始和他们见面。尽管他们支持的人赢了，他们表现得依然像叛乱分子，而不是赢家。好像他们的革命还没有结束。
Take charge of your own life, take charge of the country.
掌控你自己的生活，掌控这个国家。
I'd go to one party at some clubby leather seat whiskey bar in DC or in New York. That would get me invited to another and another. And then finally, at this one bar crawl near Trump Tower in March, I met the group I've been following for a few months now, the group this story is about.
我会去华盛顿特区或纽约的一家皮座椅威士忌酒吧参加聚会。那会让我被邀请参加另一个，再一个。最终，在三月份特朗普大厦附近的一次酒吧巡游中，我遇到了我跟踪了几个月的那个组织，也就是这个故事的主角。
So who's coming? Like, who are these guys?
那么谁会来？这些人是谁？
A lot of them are Proud Boys.
他们中的许多人是“骄傲男孩”（Proud Boys）。
What do you mean, they're Proud Boys? Can you just say what that is?
什么意思，他们是“骄傲男孩”？你能说一下那是什么吗？
Proud Boys is a fraternity. It's a fraternity. That's all. It's a fraternal organization.
“骄傲男孩”是一个兄弟会。就是一个兄弟会。就这样。这是一个兄弟组织。
Can you just say a little more about that? What do you mean it's a fraternity?
你能再多说一点吗？什么意思，它是兄弟会？
It's a fraternal organization. I mean, I just don't understand how to describe it any other way than that. I mean, that's pretty much the clearest way.
这是一个兄弟组织。我的意思是，我不明白除了这样还能怎么描述它。我的意思是，那差不多是最清晰的方式了。
This is Sal. He's 29. Huge beard. His head is a circle of hair, like that wild thing from Where the Wild Things Are. He's got a sharp tongue. It's hard to tell when he's joking. Here's how he'd introduce me sometimes at bars.
这是萨尔（Sal）。他29岁。胡子很大。他的头是一圈头发，就像《野兽家园》里的那个狂野的东西。他说话尖刻。很难判断他什么时候在开玩笑。这是他有时在酒吧向别人介绍我的方式。
This is Zoe. All right, Zoe is single. She needs a fucking man as soon as possible, and she needs to start having kids, OK?
这是佐伊。好了，佐伊单身。她需要一个该死的男人，越快越好，而且她需要开始生孩子了，明白吗？
It was hard at first to get people to explain exactly what the Proud Boys were about, and Sal gets impatient. Even though he founded the Long Island Proud Boys chapter, there are chapters all over the country.
起初很难让人们解释“骄傲男孩”到底是怎么回事，萨尔变得不耐烦了。尽管他创立了长岛的“骄傲男孩”分会，但在全国各地都有分会。
We're not allowed to talk about these things. I'm just-- I can give you like, we were drinking, we did cocaine, we got tattoos. That's pretty much it. I mean--
我们不被允许谈论这些事情。我只是——我可以告诉你，比如，我们在喝酒，我们吸食可卡因，我们纹了身。基本就是这样。我的意思是——
Sal's roommate, Cameron, put it differently.
萨尔的室友卡梅隆（Cameron）换了一种说法。
Proud Boys? What drew me to it is the value we place on family. Especially, like, fatherhood. That's a big deal.
“骄傲男孩”？吸引我的是我们对家庭的重视。特别是，比如，父亲身份。这是件大事。
The Proud Boys have these rituals, degrees.
“骄傲男孩”有这些仪式，等级。
What's second degree?
什么是二级？
I-- I can't talk about that. I mean, you'll probably find out soon, but--
我——我不能谈论那个。我的意思是，你可能很快就会知道，但是——
OK, first degree is declaring you're a Proud Boy. Second degree is getting punched while you try to name five breakfast cereals, like, to show you can focus your mind while under attack. The third is getting "Proud Boy" tattooed on your body. The Proud Boys have special greetings. Like, they yell "proud of your boy," or "uhuru" at each other. Which is this pro-Africa socialist slogan. It's kind of an ironic thing. They have theme songs.
好吧，一级是宣布你是“骄傲男孩”。二级是当你尝试列举五种早餐谷物时被拳打，比如，为了展示你在受到攻击时能够集中精神。三级是在你的身上纹上“骄傲男孩”。“骄傲男孩”有特殊的问候。比如，他们大喊“为你的男孩感到骄傲”（proud of your boy），或者彼此高喊“乌呼鲁”（uhuru）。这是非裔社会主义者的口号。这是一种讽刺的东西。他们有主题曲。
(SINGING) Proud of your boy. Bad as I've been, ma, you're in for a pleasant surprise.
（演唱）为你的男孩感到骄傲。无论我多么糟糕，妈妈，你都会有一个惊喜。
That's from Aladdin. It's not in the movie, but it is in the Broadway musical. What interested me in these guys was this thing they believed that I'd been hearing since the beginning of the presidential primaries, that they were feeling marginalized and depressed. This feeling came up so much with guys I talked to during the Trump campaign it seems like one of the driving forces that got him into office. For a lot of people, "Make America Great Again" was about "make men great again." I kept asking guys to tell me how were you marginalized? Like, what happened to you personally that made you feel like this? But every time I asked, I'd get these grand statements. Like it's the whole culture that's against them.
那出自《阿拉丁》。它不在电影里，但在百老汇音乐剧中。让我对这些人感兴趣的是他们相信的一件事，我从总统初选开始就一直听到，他们感到被边缘化和抑郁。这种感觉在特朗普竞选期间我和男人们交谈时经常出现，这似乎是促使他上台的驱动力之一。对许多人来说，“让美国再次伟大”是关于“让男人再次伟大”。我一直问男人们告诉我你们是如何被边缘化的？比如，你个人发生了什么让你感觉这样？但每次我问，我都会得到这些宏大的陈述。好像整个文化都在反对他们。
Men are very marginalized. I mean, in a lot of systems too. Especially white males. White males are the most-- white male Christians are the most marginalized group in the United States.
男人非常被边缘化。我的意思是，在很多系统中也是。尤其是白人男性。白人男性是——白人男性基督徒是美国最被边缘化的群体。
We're seeing more women getting degrees in universities. We're seeing less boys graduating from college. We're seeing-- we're seeing a switching of the roles, and I think it should be equal.
我们看到越来越多的女性在大学获得学位。我们看到越来越少的男生从大学毕业。我们看到——我们看到角色的转换，我认为应该是平等的。
Men serve a purpose. You know, we're biologically different. We're biologically a binary. Women are magical and beautiful things in what they do. And men are, you know, good at what they do. So I think what it is, being cast into, like, a non-- not a second class citizen or role, but like a subcategory.
男人有目的。你知道，我们在生物学上是不同的。我们在生物学上是二元论。女性在她们所做的事情上是神奇和美丽的。而男人，你知道，在他们所做的事情上很擅长。所以我认为它是，被投射成，就像，非——不是二等公民或角色，而是像一个子类别。
What about this compulsion to have women in action movies from Ghostbusters to Charlize Theron, she should be James Bond, and--
那么这种在动作电影中加入女性的冲动呢，从《捉鬼敢死队》到查理兹·塞隆，她应该是詹姆斯·邦德，并且——
What's bad about that?
那有什么不好的？
That's women saying they want to take over male roles. They want to be men.
那是女性说她们想要接管男性角色。她们想要成为男人。
There's no day for men besides Father's Day, and who cares about that. And those are just fathers.
除了父亲节，男人没有节日，谁在乎那个呢。而且那些只是父亲。
But as I got to know them, what surprised me the most was the foundational principle of the Proud Boys, the thing that caused them to band together. Here it is.
但当我开始了解他们时，最让我惊讶的是“骄傲男孩”的基础原则，导致他们团结在一起的事情。就是这个。
We do not masturbate except once a month, if you want. But I personally do not and don't encourage people to do so.
我们不自慰，除非一个月一次，如果你想的话。但我个人不会，也不鼓励别人这样做。
This is Franklin Wright. He works at Proud Boy Magazine.
这是富兰克林·赖特（Franklin Wright）。他在《骄傲男孩杂志》工作。
And if you do, you have to be within 10 yards of a lady, and it has to be with her consent.
如果你这样做，你必须在离女士10码的范围内，而且必须得到她的同意。
OK.
好的。
The whole no-wanks.
整个“不手淫”运动。
A quick heads up to listeners. People are going to be saying the word "wank" and its synonyms a lot for the rest of the story. Because the Proud Boys were founded, in part, as a group of men who refrain from masturbating.
给听众一个快速的预告。在故事的余下部分，人们会频繁地说出“手淫”这个词及其同义词。因为“骄傲男孩”的创立，部分原因是作为一个戒除自慰的男性团体。
It's more of a religion. Like, you can be a first degree Proud Boy, and no wanks is not a requirement. So you can be a Proud Boy and masturbate all you want. No problem. When you become initiated within the second degree, then you must adhere to no-wanks.
它更像是一种宗教。比如，你可以成为一级“骄傲男孩”，不手淫不是要求。所以你可以成为“骄傲男孩”并且想怎么自慰就怎么自慰。没问题。当你被引入二级时，你就必须遵守不手淫。
Which brings us finally to Dante Nero, the relationship expert comedian who got involved in this world. Dante was the mastermind behind no-wanks. It started for him as a personal life choice.
这最终把我们带到了但丁·尼禄，那位卷入这个世界的关系专家喜剧演员。但丁是“不手淫”背后的主脑。对他来说，这始于一个个人生活选择。
I decided not to watch porn anymore. And I just made a-- I made a statement saying "I'm not watching porn anymore, and I'm not masturbating anymore."
我决定不再看色情片了。我只是做了一个——我发表了一个声明说“我不再看色情片了，我也不再自慰了。”
Dante is striking. He's 51, bald-headed, lots of tattoos. He has a huge bone stuck through one of his ear lobes. He has his own podcast, the Beige Phillip Show, about relationships. "Beige" because he's a light-skinned black guy, "Phillip" for "Dr. Phil." Like this is his version of Dr. Phil's show. Dante used to be a male stripper. He's had sex with lots of girls, and so his sex advice comes out of those experiences. And he felt like no-wanks was a good idea for a lot of the guys who listen to his show.
但丁很引人注目。他51岁，光头，身上有很多纹身。他的一个耳垂上插着一根巨大的骨头。他有自己的播客《米色菲利普秀》（Beige Phillip Show），讨论关系。“米色”是因为他是浅肤色的黑人，“菲利普”是为了“菲尔博士”（Dr. Phil）。就像这是他版本的菲尔博士节目。但丁曾经是一名男脱衣舞者。他和很多女孩发生过关系，所以他的性建议来自于那些经历。他觉得对于很多收听他节目的男人们来说，“不手淫”是一个好主意。
That focus on the screen, and masturbating, and watching porn gave an unrealistic idea of what intimacy is, what it is to be a woman. And then when they got the rejection, they started to withdraw from the whole idea of social interaction. And they didn't even want to date anymore. This is guys who don't even want to date. And it's insane.
那种对屏幕的专注，自慰，看色情片，给了一种关于什么是亲密关系，什么是女性的不现实的想法。然后当他们被拒绝时，他们开始从整个社交互动的想法中退缩。他们甚至不想再约会了。这是那些连约会都不想的人。这太疯狂了。
Dante believed that these guys weren't going to get women to sleep with them unless they turned off the computer, got out of the house, talked to women in real life, listened to what they said, and got to know them enough to charm them into bed.
但丁认为这些男人除非关掉电脑，走出家门，在现实生活中与女性交谈，听她们在说什么，并足够了解她们，从而用魅力把她们带上床，否则他们是不会让女人和他们发生关系的。
And one day, back two years ago now, he explained this theory to the guy who would latch on to the idea and go on to create the Proud Boys, a guy named Gavin McInnes. Gavin helped found Vice Media long ago. He's kind of a libertarian punk, but now he hosts a right wing TV show on the internet. And Dante went on Gavin's show and started telling him and his viewers about how he doesn't masturbate.
有一天，就在两年前，他向那个会抓住这个想法并继续创建“骄傲男孩”的人解释了这个理论，那个人叫加文·麦金尼斯（Gavin McInnes）。加文很久以前帮助创立了Vice传媒。他是一个某种程度上的自由意志主义朋克，但现在他在互联网上主持一个右翼电视节目。但丁上了加文的节目，开始告诉他和他的观众关于他如何不自慰的事情。
And he goes "why?" And I said, "well, I find, for me, it mutes me. It mutes my masculinity to a certain extent." And he challenged me. He said "let's do a month."
他问“为什么？”我说，“好吧，我发现，对我来说，它让我静音了。它在某种程度上削弱了我的男子气概。”他挑战了我。他说“让我们做一个月。”
Write that down. Starting today.
记下来。从今天开始。
I will commit to once a month.
我承诺一个月一次。
Whoa, all right. I'll meet your once a month and raise you nothing. Once a month. Let's do it.
哇，好吧。我接受你一个月一次，并加注。一个月一次。让我们做吧。
Once a month.
一个月一次。
Agreed?
同意吗？
Agreed.
同意。
Agreed?
同意吗？
After I got off the show with Gavin, he was still-- it affected him in such a way that he constantly was talking about it. Like, every day, he was talking about no-wanks.
在我与加文结束节目后，他仍然——这对他产生了这样的影响，以至于他不断地谈论它。比如，每一天，他都在谈论“不手淫”。
Zack from Seattle, you want to know about no-wanks with a pregnant wife?
西雅图的扎克（Zack），你想知道关于一个有怀孕妻子的男人如何“不手淫”吗？
Yeah, yeah. How am I supposed to commit to no-wanks with a pregnant wife that is in no mood for sex.
是的，是的。我怎么能在怀孕的妻子没有任何性欲的情况下承诺“不手淫”。
Yes, what you're discussing, and we should probably--
是的，你正在讨论的事情，我们大概应该——
And because I was the guy that talked about it and explained it, I think that they propped me up as the guy, the pope, of no-wanks. And this whole thing was happening on its own. This whole monster was just growing about this. And I could see. I would see tweets. And every once in a while, somebody would say the pope with no-wanks. And then I got a picture of a picture of the pope in the pope garb with my face on it. They superimposed my face. Guys had t-shirts, and it just became this thing.
因为我是那个谈论并解释它的人，我认为他们把我推崇为那个“教皇”，不手淫的教皇。而整个事情在它自己的力量下发生。这个怪兽正围绕这个不断壮大。我能看到。我会看到推文。偶尔，有人会说不手淫的教皇。然后我得到了一张教皇穿着教皇服装的照片，上面是我的脸。他们合成了我的脸。男人们有T恤，这真的成了一件事。
Gavin kept inviting Dante on his show. And Gavin's show is pretty popular. Dante figured he'd get more listeners to Beige Phillip. Like, Dante is a successful working comic, but it's not full time for him. He still works a day job at the phone company. Gavin's take on no-wanks was a little different from Dante's. Gavin's show is political, and he took no-wanks and added it to the stew of right wing ideas he was talking about already.
加文不断邀请但丁上他的节目。加文的节目相当受欢迎。但丁觉得他会得到更多收听《米色菲利普》的听众。比如，但丁是一位成功的职业喜剧演员，但这对他来说不是全职。他仍然在电话公司做一份日常工作。加文对“不手淫”的看法与但丁的有点不同。加文的节目是政治性的，他接受了“不手淫”，并把它加入到他已经在谈论的右翼思想的炖锅里。
It was more than just helping guys pick up chicks. Gavin wanted the guys to stop masturbating, go out, talk to women, and then marry them, procreate, be strong American family men, help restore the natural order of things that had been knocked out of whack by feminism. This was all before the group even had a name. And when Gavin McInnes finally announced the name in May 2016, no-wanks was right in there.
这不仅仅是帮助男人们搭讪女孩。加文希望男人们停止自慰，走出去，和女性交谈，然后娶她们，繁衍后代，成为强大的美国家庭男人，帮助恢复被女权主义搞乱的自然秩序。这甚至是在该团体有名之前。当加文·麦金尼斯终于在2016年5月宣布这个名字时，“不手淫”就在其中。
I'm glad we had that no-wanks caller, because it brought me to a name for this movement I've been thinking about. We are called-- you ready for this? The Proud Boys. The Proud Boys are over race. We don't talk about-- we talk about race if you want to talk about it, but we don't have any guilt. No guilt whatsoever. No cis male guilt, none of that stuff. We're pro-gun. We want to end the drug war. We want-- we're libertarians, except when it comes to immigration. We are pro-dude. We think most women would be happier at home. We don't beat off. Well, we beat off once every 30 days. We watch porn once every 30 days. We are traditionalists. We're sort of like the alt-right without the racism.
我很高兴我们有那个“不手淫”的来电者，因为它让我为一个我一直在思考的运动想出了一个名字。我们被称为——准备好了吗？“骄傲男孩”。“骄傲男孩”是超越种族的。我们不谈论——如果你想谈论种族，我们谈论种族，但我们没有任何负罪感。完全没有负罪感。没有顺性别男性的负罪感，没有那一套东西。我们支持拥枪。我们想要结束毒品战争。我们想要——我们是自由意志主义者，除了在移民问题上。我们支持男性。我们认为大多数女性在家里会更快乐。我们不打手枪。好吧，我们每30天打一次手枪。我们每30天看一次色情片。我们是传统主义者。我们有点像是没有种族主义的“另类右翼”。
The alt-right without the racism. If you think about it a certain way, it's an ingenious sales pitch for his products. The names and affiliations of these right wing groups keep shifting around. Today, the alt-right is straight up racist, like white supremacist and anti-Semitic. Whites should have their own ethno-state. Now, Gavin's version of right wing nationalism kept some of the feelings and ideas that animate the alt-right, how affirmative action and feminism have marginalized white men, made them powerless. He kept that part. But he'll say explicitly "we're not racist." "We're not the alt-right." "We don't think white people are superior." "What we think is the West is superior. Western civilization. The West is the best."
没有种族主义的“另类右翼”。如果你以某种方式思考它，这是他产品的一个天才推销手段。这些右翼团体的名称和从属关系一直在变动。今天，“另类右翼”是直接的种族主义者，比如白人至上主义者和反犹太主义者。白人应该有自己的种族国家。现在，加文版本的右翼民族主义保留了一些激发“另类右翼”的感觉和想法，比如肯定性行动和女权主义如何边缘化了白人男性，使他们变得无能。他保留了那部分。但他会明确地说“我们不是种族主义者”。“我们不是另类右翼”。“我们不认为白人是优越的”。“我们认为的是西方是优越的。西方文明。西方是最好的。”
The Proud Boys aren't the only group like this. They keep some of the supremacy without the whiteness. It's a step removed from race. That's how he sells it, anyway.
“骄傲男孩”并不是唯一这样的团体。他们保留了一些至上主义，但没有白人色彩。这与种族隔了一步。反正他是这么卖的。
Let's talk to Jack in Texas. Jack, are you there?
让我们和得克萨斯的杰克（Jack）谈谈。杰克，你在吗？
Uhuru.
乌呼鲁。
Like, listen to how he answers this question from a caller shortly after he founded the Proud Boys.
比如，听听他在创立“骄傲男孩”后不久是如何回答来电者这个问题的。
So I was wondering, do you see Proud Boys being a-- because it's about more than just no-wanks. Do you see it being a subset of the alt-right?
所以我很好奇，你是否认为“骄傲男孩”是一个——因为这不仅仅是关于“不手淫”。你认为它是“另类右翼”的一个子集吗？
Sure, sure. My problem with the alt-right is, it rules out Wayne Dupree.
当然，当然。我对“另类右翼”的问题是，它排除了韦恩·杜普里（Wayne Dupree）。
Wayne Dupree is black, a right wing blogger.
韦恩·杜普里是黑人，一位右翼博客作者。
I'm a Western chauvinist. I'm all about the culture. Now, part of that is recognizing that white males seem to be the ones who made it and respecting that, but it doesn't mean you're not invited to the party.
我是一个西方沙文主义者。我完全是关于文化的。现在，其中的一部分是承认白人男性似乎是创造它的人并尊重这一点，但这并不意味着你没有被邀请参加派对。
It's ingenious, because clearly there's a market of guys who don't think of themselves as racists, and who don't want to suffer the social costs of their coworkers, and family, and friends finding out they're part of a racist group, but who do feel aggrieved, and marginalized, and under attack as white guys. Those are Gavin's boys, though Gavin says the focus is more on beer than aggrievement.
这很天才，因为很明显有一个男性的市场，他们不认为自己是种族主义者，也不想承受他们的同事、家人和朋友发现他们是种族主义团体一部分的社会代价，但他们确实感到委屈、边缘化，并作为白人男性受到攻击。那些是加文的男孩，尽管加文说重点更多是在啤酒上而不是委屈。
It's worth mentioning at this point that Dante Nero was not down with all these ideas. He's never watched Gavin's show. But his audience of guys who wanted to pick up girls and Gavin's audience of right wing guys who wanted to pick up girls overlapped. So we joined along for the ride. He became first degree. Obviously, no-wanks made him eligible for second degree. Often at these events, people would be getting punched and yelling out the name of five breakfast cereals. Dante skipped that, progressed straight to third degree, the tattoo.
值得一提的是，但丁·尼禄并没有认同所有这些想法。他从来没看过加文的节目。但他想搭讪女孩的听众群体和加文想搭讪女孩的右翼男性听众群体有重叠。所以我们加入其中。他成为了一级成员。显然，“不手淫”使他有资格进入二级。通常在这些活动中，人们会被拳打并大喊五种早餐谷物的名字。但丁跳过了那个，直接升级到三级，纹身。
I have it on my neck, which is--
我的脖子上有一个，也就是——
Oh, you do. It says "Proud Boy" on your neck.
哦，你有。你的脖子上写着“骄傲男孩”。
Dante felt like he understood these guys on a couple of different levels. He shares a lot of their views on men and women, that all men are essentially the same, all women basically want the same thing. And he agrees with some of the anti-politically correct "dudes are being shut down these days" stuff. "Guys can't say anything anymore without being attacked," Dante told me. Whenever they complain about it, they're called sexist.
但丁觉得他在几个不同的层面上理解这些人。他分享了他们很多关于男人和女人的观点，所有男人本质上都是一样的，所有女人基本想要同样的东西。他也同意一些反政治正确“男人这些天正在被禁言”的东西。“男人们现在什么都不能说了，不然就会被攻击，”但丁告诉我。无论他们什么时候抱怨这个，他们都会被称为性别歧视者。
One big difference between Dante and these guys, though, they mostly turned into Trump supporters. Dante is pretty liberal and doesn't like Trump. But this was before Trump became the place to put your resentment over political correctness. Anyway, they didn't talk politics with Dante much. They asked him for relationship advice.
但丁和这些人之间的一个大区别是，他们大多变成了特朗普的支持者。但丁非常自由派，不喜欢特朗普。但这是在特朗普成为把你的不满发泄在政治正确上的地方之前。总之，他们没和但丁多谈政治。他们向他寻求关系建议。
I would just sit there and talk. Like, they would go "I have this girl. I really like her. Should I approach her? She's liked my Facebook pictures." Just you know-- or maybe a guy who's 36 years old and has been with one woman in his lifetime, and he doesn't have a girlfriend, and he's going-- I never made fun of those guys, you know? I never. Empathy. Because how do you get people to come out of their shell if you're beating them into the shell about what their shortcomings are? We all have shortcomings. So empathy was one of the things that I just assumed would be a part of it. Because that's what I practice.
我只会坐在那里谈话。比如，他们会说“我有这个女孩。我真的很喜欢她。我应该接触她吗？她点了我的Facebook照片。”你知道的——或者也许是一个36岁，一生中只和过一个女人，还没有女朋友的人，他会说——我从来没有取笑过这些人，你知道吗？我从来没有。同理心。因为如果你在用他们有什么缺点来痛打他们，你怎么能让他们从壳里走出来呢？我们都有缺点。所以同理心是我认为会成为其中一部分的事情之一。因为那就是我实践的东西。
Dante was into it. He says being in a pope-like position wasn't weird for him. He explained it like he's used to being a figurehead. He helped organize the male strippers of the Bronx. He also managed a strip club and its escort service. Now he's a union steward at the phone company. And if he noticed things that alarmed him about the Proud Boys, he ignored them. It's only now, with a little hindsight, that he points to things he wishes he'd taken more seriously at the time. Like the time he brought his nephew to a Proud Boy meet-up.
但丁乐在其中。他说处在一个类似教皇的位置对他来说并不奇怪。他把它解释为他习惯了成为一个傀儡。他曾帮助组织布朗克斯的男脱衣舞者。他还管理过一家脱衣舞俱乐部及其伴游服务。现在他是电话公司的工会代表。如果他注意到关于“骄傲男孩”让他感到警惕的事情，他会忽略它们。只有现在，带着一点事后诸葛亮，他才指出那些他希望当时能更认真对待的事情。比如他带侄子去参加“骄傲男孩”聚会的那次。
He probably-- was probably the only black kid there. And he said to me that they would go, "yeah, man, it's your uncle. Cool, cool." My nephew was going to school for music. And they were like, "you know, it's great that you got out of the ghetto, and you were able to go to school." And he was like, "who said I was in the ghetto? I never said that." It was like, "it's great that you got out of a bad situation, and you were able to make it, you know, to college." And he was like, "Like, I live in Midwood, Brooklyn, which is a pretty--" Like, that's where Brooklyn College is.
他大概——大概是那里唯一的黑人小孩。他对我说是这样的，他们会说，“是的，伙计，这是你叔叔。酷，酷。”我侄子去上音乐学校。他们就像，“你知道，你能走出贫民区，能够去上学真是太棒了。”他就像，“谁说我在贫民区？我从来没这么说过。”就像，“你能从糟糕的情况中走出来，能够进入大学真是太棒了。”他就像，“我住在布鲁克林的米德伍德，这是一个相当——”就像，布鲁克林学院就在那里。
Right.
对。
It's pretty upscale. But their perception-- And I remember him telling me after, it was weird that their perception of what he was, was this stereotypical black guy that kind of made it out.
这是相当高档的。但他们的看法——我记得他事后告诉我，奇怪的是他们对他是什么样的人的看法，是那种典型的成功走出来的黑人。
He told you that?
他告诉你的？
After.
事后。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
That was a red flag, Dante says, as was the Holocaust denier video one of the Proud Boys sent him later, disputing how many people had actually died in the Holocaust. Or this other meet-up he went to.
那是一个危险信号，但丁说，就像后来其中一个“骄傲男孩”发给他的大屠杀否认视频一样，争论在大屠杀中实际上死了多少人。或者他参加的另一个聚会。
It was like a really kind of crappy bar. And I was like, "why did you choose this bar?" And the reason why they had chosen the bar was because the bar had got really bad reviews on Yelp, because the bartender called somebody a faggot. And this is why the-- like, I didn't--
那是一个非常烂的酒吧。我说，“你们为什么要选这个酒吧？”他们选择酒吧的原因是因为酒吧在Yelp上得到了非常糟糕的评价，因为酒保叫某人“基佬”（faggot）。这就是为什么——我没有——
Was there part of you that found that funny?
你有没有一部分觉得那很有趣？
No.
没有。
Dante wasn't necessarily getting more listeners to his show, but he also has a relationship consulting business. He thought maybe the Proud Boys would become customers. He seems like he was probably having fun sometimes, though he won't cop to that. He had a million other things going on too, his own show, his day job, bit parts in movies. And, he says, he liked the idea that when he was in the mix he could push back on some of their ideas.
但丁并没有因此获得更多的节目听众，但他也有一项关系咨询业务。他想也许“骄傲男孩”会成为客户。他看起来有时候可能玩得很开心，尽管他不承认。他还有一百万其他事情在进行，他自己的节目，日常工作，电影中的小角色。而且，他说，他喜欢当他混在其中时，他可以反驳他们的一些想法。
Like, you thought of yourself as a black ambassador almost.
比如，你几乎把自己当成了黑人大使。
Yeah, I guess. I mean, I thought that I could-- I would-- I thought that I could give-- that it wouldn't be this echo chamber, if I was part of it. Honestly, I don't even know what "uhuru" means. I knew it was their call. I noticed it was very important. I know that they looked up to me. I knew that I could-- that if I was part of this, that I could be a voice that they weren't getting from anything else.
是的，我想。我的意思是，我以为我可以——我会——我以为我可以给——如果我参与其中，它就不会是这个回音室。老实说，我甚至不知道“乌呼鲁”是什么意思。我知道那是他们的口号。我注意到它非常重要。我知道他们崇拜我。我知道我可以——如果我参与其中，我可以成为他们从其他任何地方都得不到的声音。
And then something happened that really freaked him out. Warning, this involves a racial slur. He got an invite to the Proud Boys' Facebook page, and he went on there.
然后发生了一件事，真的让他吓坏了。警告，这涉及种族歧视用语。他收到了一份进入“骄傲男孩”Facebook页面的邀请，他进去了。
And there was nigger this and nigger that, Nazi this. And there was, like, this white supremacist stuff. And I'm like, "I'm the pope. You're talking about black people like this." There's pictures of, you know, the old cartoons with the black dudes with the big lips and the bone. Like, there was all this stuff on it, and I was like "yo!" I even said this to Gavin. I go, "man, I'm not really comfortable with this at all. Because they're talking about me!" And Gavin actually screamed on them and said, "listen, the pope doesn't want to come on anymore, because all this racist stuff needs to stop."
到处都是“黑鬼”（nigger）这个，那个的，纳粹这个。而且有，比如，这种白人至上主义的东西。我就说，“我是教皇。你们正在这样谈论黑人。”有照片，你知道，那种老的漫画，有着大嘴唇和骨头的黑人家伙。就像，上面有所有这些东西，我说“嘿！”我甚至对加文说了。我说，“伙计，我一点也不舒服。因为他们在谈论我！”加文实际上对他们尖叫，并说，“听着，教皇不想再来了，因为所有这些种族主义的东西都需要停止。”
So he actually took a stand with it, but you've already done everything to kind of get these guys to that point already. Like, how do you make a left turn off of that once they're already there?
所以他实际上对此表明了立场，但你已经做了所有事情来促使这些人达到那个程度了。比如，一旦他们已经在那里了，你如何让他们左转回来？
I guess that's what I wonder is like, did you have a theory in your mind as to why all this racist stuff was showing up on a Proud Boy's Facebook page?
我想这就是我好奇的地方，你心里有没有一个理论，关于为什么所有这些种族主义的东西会出现在“骄傲男孩”的Facebook页面上？
It was the natural progression. I think it was the natural progression in terms of "OK, we're the greatest. We're this." You're not! You're 22 years old. You haven't done anything. I'm not saying that they don't have the potential to be great, but who's great at 22? And your whiteness doesn't make you great. Neither does my blackness make me great. It's the content of what I do on a day to day basis, and how I operate on a day to day basis. But when you are in this vacuum and everybody's jerking each other off-- I mean funny--
这是自然的发展。我认为这是自然的发展，就是说“好的，我们是最伟大的。我们是这个。”你不是！你22岁。你什么都没做。我不是说他们没有伟大的潜力，但谁在22岁时伟大呢？你的白人身份并不能让你伟大。我的黑人身份也不能让我伟大。这取决于我每天所做的事情的内容，以及我每天运作的方式。但当你处在这个真空中，每个人都在互相自慰——我的意思是好笑——
I mean, maybe not.
我的意思是，也许不是。
Right, maybe not, but socially jerking each other, "we're great, we're the best," where is growth? If you're already great, where is the need for growth?
对，也许不是，但从社交上互相自慰，“我们很伟大，我们是最好的，”成长在哪里？如果你已经很伟大了，哪里需要成长？
Dante did not see Gavin's show in mid June of this summer, when the guy who organized the rally in Charlottesville, Jason Kessler, joined Gavin and invited the Proud Boys to come down.
但丁在今年夏天六月中旬没有看加文的节目，当时夏洛茨维尔集会的组织者杰森·凯斯勒加入了加文，并邀请“骄傲男孩”参加。
We've got Jason Kessler on the line, right? Is he still there? He's over there in Virginia, near Washington DC. Where are you?
我们要和杰森·凯斯勒连线，对吗？他还在那吗？他在弗吉尼亚，离华盛顿特区很近。你在哪？
Yeah, I'm here in Charlottesville, Virginia, where we're going to have the Unite the Right rally on August 12th. It's going to be international news, so you won't forget it. Charlottesville, Virginia.
是的，我在夏洛茨维尔，弗吉尼亚州，我们将要在8月12日举行“团结右翼”集会。这将是国际新闻，所以你不会忘记它。夏洛茨维尔，弗吉尼亚州。
OK, we will not forget Charlottesville, Virginia.
好的，我们不会忘记夏洛茨维尔，弗吉尼亚州。
Jason was just getting to know the Proud Boys chapter in Virginia. He and Gavin talked about that and some ideas they have in common.
杰森当时刚刚开始了解弗吉尼亚州的“骄傲男孩”分会。他和加文谈论了那个以及他们共同拥有的一些想法。
I want to stand up for white people. I want to stand up for Western civilization. I want to stand up for men. I want to stand up for Christians.
我想为白人挺身而出。我想为西方文明挺身而出。我想为男人挺身而出。我想为基督徒挺身而出。
I'm against immigration.
我反对移民。
These are the kind of speech that are outlawed.
这些是被取缔的言论类型。
Shortly after that it seems Jason became a Proud Boy himself, second degree. Punches, breakfast cereals.
在那之后不久，似乎杰森自己也成为了“骄傲男孩”，二级。拳打，早餐谷物。
Thanks for coming on the show. I like you more than a friend.
谢谢你来上节目。我把你当朋友看。
Good to be with you, Gavin.
很高兴和你在一起，加文。
That's what Gavin always says at the end of an interview for some reason. He was unsure whether to endorse this event or not.
那是加文出于某种原因在采访结束时总是说的话。他不确定是否要支持这次活动。
He's a nice boy. I go back and forth on that thing. It has Confederate flags on it and stuff. On the one hand, I'm not-- I'm not scared of being associated with Richard Spencer. On the other hand--
他是个好孩子。在那件事上我反复权衡。它有联盟旗帜之类的东西。一方面，我不——我不怕与理查德·斯宾塞（Richard Spencer）联系在一起。另一方面——
Richard Spencer is a famous white nationalist leader.
理查德·斯宾塞是一位著名的白人民族主义领导人。
On the other hand, I want to get back to what we're really about, which is beer.
另一方面，我想回到我们真正的主题，也就是啤酒。
We know now, of course, how that rally turned out. Tiki torches, actual Nazis, and white supremacists, and then a woman was killed. After it happened, Gavin McInnes insisted that event had nothing to do with the Proud Boys. He did not go. As it got closer, he told the Proud Boys not to go, because it seemed like white supremacists were going to be involved. They were.
我们现在当然知道那场集会的结果如何了。提基火把，真正的纳粹，还有白人至上主义者，然后一名女性被杀。事情发生后，加文·麦金尼斯坚称那次活动与“骄傲男孩”无关。他没有去。当它临近时，他告诉“骄傲男孩”不要去，因为似乎白人至上主义者将会参与其中。他们确实参与了。
According to Gavin, any Proud Boy who went to the event-- we know there were at least two-- got kicked out of the Proud Boys. And Gavin now says the guy who organized the rally, Jason Kessler, is not a Proud Boy, never was, and was spying on them. But Kessler has told us he was a member of the group. He was going to meetings, and there's video of him going through the second degree initiation-- getting punched and yelling out breakfast cereals. In any case, Gavin had him back on the show to yell at him.
据加文说，任何参加该活动的“骄傲男孩”——我们知道至少有两个——都被踢出了“骄傲男孩”。加文现在说组织集会的那个人杰森·凯斯勒不是“骄傲男孩”，从来都不是，而且是在监视他们。但凯斯勒告诉我们他是该组织的成员。他去参加会议，还有他经历二级入会——被打和喊出早餐谷物的视频。无论如何，加文让他回到了节目中去对他咆哮。
And I think this blood, the blood of this girl, I mean, it's obviously on the hands of the guy driving the car, but it's also on your hands!
我认为这个血，这个女孩的血，我的意思是，很明显在开车的那个人的手上，但它也在你的手上！
No, that's absolutely not! And you're trying to cuck and save your own ass!
不，绝对不是！你是在试图通过把责任推给我来保全你自己！
No, I'm not! When the mayor said no permit, you knew a fight was going to go down!
不，我不是！当市长说没有许可证时，你就知道会发生冲突！
You cuck yourself for people to save your marriage or your reputation, whatever. And it's just not right, man. You brought me up here to be a patsy for you, just like the Charlottesville government.
你为了保住你的婚姻或名声之类的东西把自己当成了替罪羊。这根本不对，伙计。你把我带到这里来做你的替罪羊，就像夏洛茨维尔政府一样。
Oh, I'm saying the exact opposite. I'm suspicious of you--
哦，我说的恰恰相反。我很怀疑你——
Gavin accepts absolutely no responsibility for some of the guys in his group turning alt-right or white supremacist-esque. Even Sal from the beginning of this story, that Long Island Proud Boy I met at the bar, he went to Charlottesville. He took a selfie with David Duke and tweeted it. He's out of the group now.
加文对他的组织中有些人变成“另类右翼”或白人至上主义倾向不负任何责任。即使是故事开始时的萨尔，我在酒吧遇到的那个长岛“骄傲男孩”，他也去了夏洛茨维尔。他和戴维·杜克（David Duke）自拍并把它发到了推特上。他现在已经离开了组织。
The Proud Boys have zero culpability, not just with his drift right but with the far right in general. And I would argue, if you're looking for someone to blame, that's the leftist media constantly crapping on these young men and telling them that they're evil and that they suck, and I think that the liberal media banding around the word "Nazi" to where it means 50% of the population, is making a lot of young men revolt and go, "Yeah, you know what? I am. How's that, bitch?" I'm not talking to you, calling you a bitch, by the way.
“骄傲男孩”零责任，不仅是他向右漂移，而且是对极右翼整体。我想说，如果你在找人责备，那就是左翼媒体不断地在这些年轻人身上拉屎，告诉他们他们是邪恶的，他们很烂，我认为自由派媒体围绕“纳粹”这个词，把它定义为50%的人口，正在让许多年轻人反抗并说，“是的，你知道吗？我是。那又怎样，婊子？”顺便说一句，我不是在对你说话，叫你婊子。
I know.
我知道。
Fact is, there's overlap between what the Proud Boys espouse and what white supremacist groups believe. I ran through the list for Gavin.
事实是，“骄傲男孩”所拥护的与白人至上主义团体所相信的之间有重叠。我为加文列举了清单。
"Our culture is better than yours. Our women need to stay home and make more babies. Our country has no more space for immigrants. We are being persecuted." Those are your ideas. Those are ideas I see in white supremacist groups. Do you see that you guys have those same ideas?
“我们的文化比你们的好。我们的女人需要呆在家里生更多的孩子。我们的国家没有空间容纳移民了。我们正在受到迫害。”这些是你的想法。这些是我在白人至上主义团体中看到的想法。你看到你们有这些相同的想法了吗？
Yes, I do. And that's the plight of the right in many ways. This is why William F Buckley had to struggle hard to get Nazis out of National Review. They get attracted to this. But to sort of glom on all this pattern and try to suck everyone into Charlottesville, including the president, is insane. It's an obsession. It's a compulsion. You're falling into the logical fallacy of all cats are mammals, all dogs are mammals, all cats are dogs.
是的，我看到了。这是右翼在许多方面的困境。这就是为什么小威廉·F·巴克利（William F Buckley）不得不努力将纳粹赶出《国家评论》（National Review）。他们被这个吸引。但要把所有这些模式联系起来，并试图把每个人都拉进夏洛茨维尔，包括总统，是疯狂的。这是一种痴迷。这是一种强迫症。你陷入了所有的猫都是哺乳动物，所有的狗都是哺乳动物，所有的猫都是狗的逻辑谬误中。
I think what I've documented is that when you have a group that is founded in part around male resentment and aggrievement without racism--
我认为我记录下来的是，当你有一个部分建立在男性不满和委屈之上而没有种族主义的团体时——
It's not founded around male resentment.
它不是建立在男性不满之上的。
Some people are skipping the "without racism" part. And that's what I'm seeing.
有些人跳过了“没有种族主义”的部分。而那正是，我看到的。
I know that's your thesis. And I'm telling you you're totally and utterly wrong. I'm telling you, Zoe, your entire angle is wrong. Because you found some similarities, because you want to link this to Charlottesville. There was no Proud Boys contingent at that thing. I'm afraid there's no angle here. And the angle of the Proud Boys is not resentment. It's not this animosity. It's just another men's club!
我知道那是你的论点。我告诉你你完全彻底错了。我告诉你，佐伊，你的整个角度都错了。因为你发现了一些相似之处，因为你想把这个联系到夏洛茨维尔。那件事上没有“骄傲男孩”的人。恐怕这里没有角度。而“骄傲男孩”的角度不是不满。不是这种敌意。这只是另一个男人的俱乐部！
Dante didn't know that the guy who organized the Charlottesville rally had been a member of the Proud Boys, and that he'd gone on Gavin's show promoting it. I was the one who told him that during our interview. He had a hard time with it.
但丁不知道夏洛茨维尔集会的组织者曾是“骄傲男孩”的成员，也不知道他上了加文的节目推广它。在我们的采访中，是我告诉他的。他对此感到很难受。
That makes my stomach kind of queasy. Really. Like, man. Well, the first thing I'm thinking about is, I gotta get a cover-up for this tattoo. That's got to happen immediately.
这让我的胃有点恶心。真的。像，伙计。好吧，我想到的第一件事是，我必须给这个纹身找个遮盖。这必须立即发生。
Just because there's a Jason Kessler or there's a Sal, like, does that mean that there's a slippery slope with all these Proud Boys gonna tumble down it?
仅仅因为有一个杰森·凯斯勒或一个萨尔，比如，那是否意味着所有的“骄傲男孩”都会滑向那个滑坡？
I think a lot of them could. I think it could. I think they're susceptible to it. I think given the right combination of things happening and the right timing, yeah.
我认为他们中的很多人会。我认为会的。我认为他们很容易受到影响。我认为鉴于发生的事情的正确组合和正确的时机，是的。
Well, what is it about that group that created that slippery slope?
那么，那个团体里有什么东西造成了那个滑坡？
The perception of being disenfranchised. Not even the reality of it. The fact that you can't just do-- just being a mediocre white dude gets you certain things.
被剥夺权利的感觉。甚至不是那种现实。仅仅是做一个平庸的白人伙计就能让你得到某些东西这一事实。
I did talk to guys who were in it for the beer and the friendship and the no-wank solidarity, but also obviously, guys who were in it for "the West is the best." And as Dante says, that's not such a big jump over to "white people are the best." Which really upsets him. He told me this story, that the very first time Dante had Gavin on his podcast, like back two years ago now, they sat down, he and Gavin, and started talking about politics.
我确实和那些为了啤酒和友谊以及“不手淫”团结在一起的人交谈过，但显然，也和那些为了“西方是最好的”在一起的人交谈过。正如但丁所说，那离“白人是最好的”并没有太大的跨度。这真的让他很困扰。他告诉我这个故事，就在但丁第一次在播客上邀请加文时，比如两年前，他和加文坐下来，开始谈论政治。
I said, "you know what's interesting is how confident you are about your ideas." And I go, "in general, white dudes that have these ideas, you're so confident about this, but you've never been right on the ethical side of history ever, in the course of history. Coming here and taking the land from the Indians and genocide of Indians, when you talk about the Atlantic slave trade, then when you talk about the intern-- Japanese internment camps. You have Jim Crow. Then you have the mass incarceration. You have police brutality."
我说，“你知道有趣的是你对你的想法有多自信。”我走，“总的来说，有这些想法的白人伙计，你们对此如此自信，但你们在历史进程中，在道德层面从来没有对过。来到这里从印第安人手中夺取土地和印第安人种族灭绝，当你谈论大西洋奴隶贸易时，然后当你谈论日本拘留营时。你们有吉姆·克劳法。然后你们有大规模监禁。你们有警察暴行。”
And I go, "every time you come up with one of these ideas, you always think you're right, but you're wrong every time in history." I go, "just like this Muslim ban thing that you guys, or deporting the Mexicans, you're sure about this. But you are never right. Never in history have you been right. And history has always shown that because of your lack of-- your insensitivity, your lack of empathy, you don't see it from the oppressed position. You think you're right, and you have the confidence of somebody who is always right when you're always wrong, just never been right."
我走，“每次你们提出这些想法之一时，你们总是认为你们是对的，但你们在历史上每次都错了。”我走，“就像你们这些家伙的穆斯林禁令，或者驱逐墨西哥人，你们对此很确定。但你们从来没有对过。在历史上你们从来没有对过。历史总是表明，由于你们缺乏——你们的麻木不仁，你们缺乏同理心，你们没有从被压迫的位置来看待它。你们认为你们是对的，你们拥有总是正确的人的自信，而在你们总是错的时候，只是从来没有正确过。”
And he kind of was like, "yeah, that's a good point." After that, we never really talked about politics.
他有点像，“是的，那是一个好的观点。”在那之后，我们就没怎么谈论政治了。
This is basically the opposite of "the West is the best," obviously. Dante is definitely upset about Charlottesville. He's upset someone died. He's upset about Nazis. But in the mix of what's frustrating Dante right now is, he feels like the guys misunderstood no-wanks. And the thing they misunderstood about no-wanks is the same thing he thinks they misunderstand about history. They leave out the empathy. No-wanks, as Dante saw it, was supposed to lead to a friendlier, more understanding, and more inclusive world. Or kinda.
显然，这基本上是“西方是最好的”的对立面。但丁对夏洛茨维尔肯定感到不安。他对有人死了感到不安。他对纳粹感到不安。但在但丁现在感到沮丧的事情中，他觉得这些人误解了“不手淫”。而他们对“不手淫”误解的东西，和他认为他们对历史误解的东西是一样的。他们丢掉了同理心。正如但丁所看到的，“不手淫”本来是为了带来一个更友好、更理解、更具包容性的世界。或者某种程度上。
I would say "empathy." I would talk about empathy. I started to talk about empathy, understanding the need to see, see it from a woman's perspective. Because how do you-- how do you-- how do you get a woman and have a real intimate relationship if you don't have empathy for what she's going through? Look, I think the anti-pc culture is-- I think that that's a reasonable thing. I think it has gone nuts. I mean, I'm a comic. I want to be able to say what I want to say.
我会说“同理心”。我会谈论同理心。我开始谈论同理心，理解从女性角度来看的需要。因为你怎么——你怎么——如果你对她正在经历的事情没有同理心，你怎么能得到一个女人并拥有一段真正的亲密关系呢？看，我认为反PC文化是——我认为那是合理的事情。我认为它已经疯了。我的意思是，我是个喜剧演员。我想要能够说出我想说的话。
Yeah.
对。
But to the same token, you cannot not have the empathy to know that there are historical references to the reason why you can't say the things that you want to say.
但同样，你不能没有同理心去知道有历史参考资料，这就是为什么你不能说你想说的话的原因。
Maybe those Charlottesville guys should have stayed at home wanking, Dante says. Then they wouldn't have taken the initiative to go show up at a Nazi rally.
也许那些夏洛茨维尔的家伙应该呆在家里自慰，但丁说。那样他们就不会采取主动去参加纳粹集会了。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our program. Coming up, a grudge match between two men, one black, one white, and where that leads. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，两个男人，一个黑人，一个白人之间的宿怨，以及那会通向哪里。那将在从芝加哥公共广播电台继续我们的节目一分钟后播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, White Haze. We try to make sense of all those overlapping groups that marched in Charlottesville, the fuzzy mix of alt-right and alt-light, and all the others that were there, and how people who say that they are not racist and not white supremacists have ended up in a melting pot with people who are.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“白色迷雾”。我们试图理清那些在夏洛茨维尔游行的所有重叠团体的含义，即“另类右翼”和“另类轻量级”的模糊混合，以及所有在那里的其他人，以及那些说他们不是种族主义者和不是白人至上主义者的人，最终如何与那些是的人混在了一个大熔炉里。
One of the things that we wondered here on our show after Charlottesville is why are there so many of these little groups? Like, why are there a lot of them? Why are they small? Like, why isn't there some big umbrella organization to advance their interests? And we were surprised to learn that for decades in the white power movement, this was a strategy. It was an actual strategy. And it was put into place in the 1980s. The strategy was called "leaderless resistance." And the white power movement adopted it because the FBI and federal law enforcement were successfully planting informants and covert agents inside the ranks.
在夏洛茨维尔之后，我们在节目中想知道的一件事是，为什么有这么多这些小团体？比如，为什么有很多？为什么它们很小？比如，为什么没有某个大的伞形组织来推进他们的利益？我们很惊讶地了解到，在白人权力运动中，几十年来，这是一种策略。这是一种实际的策略。它在20世纪80年代被付诸实施。这种策略被称为“无领袖抵抗”。白人权力运动采用了它，因为联邦调查局和联邦执法部门成功地在队伍中安插了线人和卧底特工。
So leaderless resistance is a model of cell terrorism in which each activist and cell is supposed to act without direct communication with any other cell or with movement leadership.
所以无领袖抵抗是一种细胞恐怖主义模式，其中每个活动家和细胞应该在没有与任何其他细胞或运动领导层直接沟通的情况下行动。
Kathleen Belew is a historian at the University of Chicago, and she's written about this period in the '70s and '80s and the white power movement for a book that's coming out next year. She says with leaderless resistance, people all over the country were reading the same propaganda, the same kind of playbook, if you will. But they all acted on their own. They were uncoordinated.
凯瑟琳·贝莱（Kathleen Belew）是芝加哥大学的历史学家，她为明年出版的一本书写了关于70和80年代白人权力运动的这段时期。她说有了无领袖抵抗，全国各地的人们都在阅读同样的宣传，同样的剧本，如果你愿意的话。但他们都是自己行动的。他们是不协调的。
She says the idea for leaderless resistance was popularized by a man named Louis Beam, who was in the Klan and in the group Aryan Nations in 1983. She says we know how he sent out the memo to the rest of the movement on this.
她说无领袖抵抗的想法是由路易斯·比姆（Louis Beam）普及的，他在1983年是三K党和雅利安国（Aryan Nations）团体的成员。她说我们知道他是如何向运动的其他部分发送关于这个的备忘录的。
There's an essay called Leaderless Resistance that's published in a collection of essays called Essays of a Klansman. So it was printed in '83, '89.
有一篇名为“无领袖抵抗”的文章发表在一本名为《三K党人文章》的文集中。所以它是在83年，89年印刷的。
So he publishes it in a book. Is there also, like, a meeting where they all come together, and they discuss, and they take a vote, and they're like, "yes, that's what we're going to do."
所以他在书中发表了它。是否还有一个会议，在那里他们聚在一起，讨论，进行投票，他们像，“是的，那就是我们要做的。”
So whether there is a vote is not clear, but there is a meeting. There is a meeting called the Aryan Nations World Congress. And this had been happening since the 1970s at the Hayden Lake compound in Idaho, which is where Aryan Nations is located. And the World Congress is both a political meeting and a social meeting. So there are fiery speeches about any number of causes important to this movement, and then there's also a big spaghetti dinner and volleyball games. At the meeting--
所以是否有投票不清楚，但有一个会议。有一个会议叫雅利安国世界大会。自20世纪70年代以来，这一直发生在爱达荷州海登湖的复合体中，那是雅利安国所在地。世界大会既是政治会议也是社交会议。所以有关于这个运动重要的任何数量事业的激烈演讲，然后还有大意大利面晚餐和排球比赛。在会议上——
Can we just pause? What do we know about the spaghetti dinners and the volleyball games?
我们可以暂停一下吗？关于意大利面晚餐和排球比赛我们知道什么？
People talk about the spaghetti dinners. The spaghetti dinners turn out to be a really important part of it, because it's sort of how the social life of the movement is maintained. And one of the interesting things about this is that to have the spaghetti dinners, you really need to have the participation of women. And Mrs. Butler, who is the wife of the leader of Aryan Nations, is in charge of the spaghetti.
人们谈论意大利面晚餐。意大利面晚餐被证明是其中非常重要的一部分，因为它基本上是运动的社交生活如何维持的方式。其中有趣的一点是，为了举行意大利面晚餐，你真的需要女性的参与，而巴特勒夫人（Mrs. Butler），雅利安国领导人的妻子，负责意大利面。
It's interesting thinking about, like, they're celebrating their white heritage. It makes me think about how for a period in this country Italians weren't included in that heritage, were they?
想到他们庆祝他们的白色遗产，这让我想到有一段时间在这个国家意大利人并不包括在那个遗产中，他们是吗？
Indeed. And actually, yes, there are a number of recipes that turn up in the women's publication of this movement that are similarly eyebrow-raising in that way. So for instance, one of the major, major women's circulars that has columns in it called From the Mouths of Little Aryans, and is a pretty apocalyptic magazine, actually. Like, that magazine argues that women will actually have to fight in a race war. They also have recipes for a taco pizza.
确实。事实上，是的，在女性的出版物中出现了一些食谱，在那种方式上同样令人侧目。所以例如，主要的，主要的女性通告之一，有标题为“来自小雅利安人的嘴里”的专栏，而且实际上是一本相当末日的杂志。像，那本杂志主张女性实际上将不得不在种族战争中战斗。他们还有塔科披萨（taco pizza）的食谱。
OK, we digress.
好的，我们离题了。
Belew says the FBI believes leaderless resistance was actually discussed at this event. Several people from the movement testified that it was. Others denied there was a real plan like this.
贝莱说联邦调查局相信无领袖抵抗实际上在这次活动中被讨论过。几名来自运动的人作证说确实讨论过。其他人否认有这样的实际计划。
But what is clear is that after this meeting in July of 1983, something changes. Because their strategy changes very notably. They spend a lot less time on coordinated public rallies and political campaigns, although that activity continues. And the violence and underground activity immediately ticks up.
但清楚的是，在1983年7月的这次会议之后，有些事情改变了。因为他们的策略改变得非常显著。他们花在协调公开集会和政治运动上的时间少多了，尽管这种活动继续进行。而暴力和地下活动立即增加。
Out of that come incidents like the Oklahoma City bombing in 1995, in which 168 people died. Which Belew says is often mistakenly thought of as the work of a lone bomber, Timothy McVeigh and a co-conspirator, but fits entirely the sort of thing that an activist would do as part of leaderless resistance. And this is the way that the white power movement worked for decades, small groups, people staying below the radar to avoid attention and avoid prosecution. And that is what is changing today.
由此产生了诸如1995年俄克拉荷马城爆炸案之类的事件，其中168人死亡。贝莱说这经常被错误地认为是孤独的炸弹客，蒂莫西·麦克维（Timothy McVeigh）和一个同谋的作品，但完全符合活动家作为无领袖抵抗的一部分会做的事情。这就是白人权力运动几十年来运作的方式，小团体，人们保持在雷达之下以避免注意并避免起诉。而这就是今天正在改变的东西。
Talking to people who are knowledgeable about what's going on with white nationalist groups today, including researchers at the Southern Poverty Law Center, what they say is that what's happening today is that leaders are stepping forward. They are becoming public figures. And the separate little groups, they are, in fact, trying to band together. Maybe not to become one big organization, but to work together when it's helpful.
与了解今天白人民族主义团体情况的人交谈，包括南方贫困法律中心的研究人员，他们所说的是，今天正在发生的是领导人正在站出来。他们正在成为公众人物。而分开的小团体，实际上正在试图团结起来。也许不是成为一个大的组织，而是当有帮助时一起工作。
The name of the rally in Charlottesville, after all, was "Unite the Right." This was a public rally where groups came together in common cause, where they were proudly visible. And that's what's different about this new incarnation of the white nationalist movement today. That's what's different from the last few decades.
夏洛茨维尔集会的名称，毕竟是“团结右翼”。这是一场公开的集会，团体聚集在一起，为了共同的事业，他们自豪地显眼。而这就是今天白人民族主义运动这个新化身的不同之处。这与过去几十年不同。
And now we have arrived at Act Two of our program, Act Two, Phone Calls to an Undisclosed Location. OK, so remember back during Act One, during Zoe's story, when the guy who organized the rally in Charlottesville, after the rally, he went on to Gavin McInnes's show, and the two of them argued over who was to blame for the death of that woman who was killed at the rally. And Gavin McInnes was pretty direct.
现在我们已经到达我们节目的第二幕，第二幕，给未公开地点打电话。好的，所以记得第一幕期间，在佐伊的故事期间，夏洛茨维尔集会的组织者，在集会之后，他上了加文·麦金尼斯的节目，他们俩争论谁该为集会上被杀的那个女人的死亡负责。加文·麦金尼斯非常直接。
I think this blood, the blood of this girl, I mean, it's obviously on the hands of the guy driving the car, but it's also on your hands!
我认为这个血，这个女孩的血，我的意思是，很明显在开车的那个人的手上，但它也在你的手上！
No, that's absolutely not. And you're trying to cuck and save your own ass.
不，绝对不是。你是在试图通过把责任推给我来保全你自己。
No, I'm not!
不，我不是！
The organizer of the rally, Jason Kessler, said he could not be blamed for that death. And one of our producers, Robyn Semien, saw this quote that Kessler gave somewhere else, where he talked about the same thing, about who was to blame. And the quote was really interesting. In that quote, Jason Kessler put the blame on somebody else, somebody very, very specific. Here's Robyn.
集会的组织者杰森·凯斯勒说他不能为那次死亡负责。而我们的制作人之一，罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien），在别处看到了凯斯勒给出的这个引述，他在谈论同样的事情，关于谁该负责。这个引述真的很有趣。在那个引述中，杰森·凯斯勒把责任推给了别人，一个非常，非常具体的人。这是罗宾。
I read about it in an article days after the rally. When asked what prompted him to organize the rally, Jason Kessler said, "I didn't do it. Wes Bellamy did." Wes Bellamy is the vice mayor of Charlottesville, and the only black member of city council. Jason Kessler put the blame on him, not the mayor, not city council, not the police. Wes Bellamy.
我在集会几天后的一篇文章中读到了它。当被问及是什么促使他组织集会时，杰森·凯斯勒说，“我没做。韦斯·贝拉米（Wes Bellamy）做的。”韦斯·贝拉米是夏洛茨维尔的副市长，也是市议会中唯一的黑人成员。杰森·凯斯勒把责任推给了他，不是市长，不是市议会，不是警察。韦斯·贝拉米。
I knew about Wes Bellamy before I read that quote, because I saw him on TV that Saturday, after the president's Many Sides press conference. Was Bellamy was doing interviews. He's handsome, black, young, and memorably, he was in a white t-shirt that said "Menace 2 Supremacy" on it. The "to" like the number two in Menace 2 Society. He stood out. I liked it.
在那篇引述之前我就知道韦斯·贝拉米，因为我在那个周六，总统的“许多方面”（Many Sides）新闻发布会之后在电视上看到了他。贝拉米在接受采访。他英俊，黑人，年轻，并且令人难忘的是，他穿着一件白色的T恤，上面写着“Menace 2 Supremacy”（威胁至上主义）。“to”像“Menace 2 Society”里的数字二。他很突出。我喜欢它。
Kessler lives in Charlottesville, and it seems like he's had a maniacal focus on Bellamy for almost a year. It started with the statue. Bellamy wanted to remove it. Kessler got pissed. Then a bunch happened. When Bellamy and others protested racism outside an Italian restaurant, Kessler showed up and ate pasta in their faces.
凯斯勒住在夏洛茨维尔，看起来他已经对贝拉米有近一年的狂热关注了。它始于那个雕像。贝拉米想要移除它。凯斯勒被激怒了。然后发生了一堆事情。当贝拉米和其他人在一家意大利餐厅外抗议种族主义时，凯斯勒出现了并在他们面前吃意大利面。
Kessler exposed scandalous tweets from Bellamy's old Twitter account, which cost Bellamy his jobs at a high school and at the State Board of Education. But Bellamy's supporters didn't seem to care. Back and forth, many failed attempts by Jason Kessler to undo Wes Bellamy, including, last December, Kessler showing up at a council meeting to look Bellamy in the eye while blaring Tom Petty's I Won't Back Down from a portable speaker. So I wanted Wes Bellamy to talk to me about all that.
凯斯勒曝光了贝拉米旧推特账户中的丑闻推文，这让他失去了高中和州教育委员会的工作。但贝拉米的支持者似乎不在乎。来来回回，杰森·凯斯勒试图撤销韦斯·贝拉米的多次失败尝试，包括去年十二月，凯斯勒出现在议会会议上，一边用便携式扬声器播放汤姆·佩蒂（Tom Petty）的《我不会后退》（I Won't Back Down），一边注视着贝拉米的眼睛。所以我想要韦斯·贝拉米和我谈谈所有那些事情。
I want to talk about Jason Kessler.
我想谈谈杰森·凯斯勒。
JK.
JK。
Are you on an initial basis?
你们在初始阶段吗？
No, I mean, I don't really talk about that gentleman. He's free to do what he wants to do.
不，我的意思是，我并不真的谈论那位绅士。他可以自由地做他想做的事。
I had told him I wanted to talk about the rally and the events leading up to the rally, but I only realized sitting in front of him that I assumed he knew that meant talking about the man who organized the rally and his history with him. I ran that Kessler quote by him, or where Kessler said he organized the rally because of Bellamy.
我告诉他我想要谈论集会以及导致集会的事件，但我坐在他面前才意识到我假设他知道这意味着谈论组织集会的那个人以及他与他的历史。我把他提到的那篇凯斯勒引述给了他，或者说凯斯勒说他组织集会是因为贝拉米。
He said, "I didn't do it. Wes Bellamy did it."
他说，“我没做。韦斯·贝拉米做的。”
All right. I didn't see that. I don't really, again, pay attention, a lot of attention to what he says, but--
好的。我没看到那个。我不真的，再说一遍，注意，非常注意他说的话，但是——
Why would you say that?
你为什么会这么说？
They, he and his posse, they firmly believe that I am-- I mean, they've said this on several occasions. I'm a huge threat to the quote, unquote, "white race." I'm a threat to them having what is theirs. Like, I'm taking it away. I'm a threat to what they believe to be the pure white race and Western civilization, and the way in which they do things. I'm a black male, who's 30, who is very vocal, who is in this position, who has a lot of support. And if that scares them, if that makes them believe this is my fault, that just, like, shows what kind of people they are. You have to take accountability. Wes Bellamy didn't plan an alt-right rally.
他们，他和他的同伙，他们坚定地相信我是——我的意思是，他们在几次场合说过这个。我是对所谓的“白人种族”的巨大威胁。我是他们拥有属于他们东西的威胁。比如，我正在拿走它。我是对他们相信是纯白种族和西方文明的威胁，以及他们做事的方式。我是一个30岁的黑人男性，非常直言不讳，处于这个位置，拥有很多支持。如果这吓到了他们，如果这让他们相信这是我的错，那只是，就像，展示了他们是什么样的人。你必须承担责任。韦斯·贝拉米没有计划一场另类右翼集会。
He was candid and had lots to say, until I mentioned I'd be talking to Kessler for my story, and then his whole body changed. He looked annoyed, stopped looking me in the eye.
他很坦率，有很多话要说，直到我提到我会为我的故事和凯斯勒谈话，然后他的整个身体都变了。他看起来很烦，不再看着我的眼睛。
I'm talking to Kessler tomorrow, and that's fine.
我明天和凯斯勒谈话，那很好。
You're gonna put us in a story together? You didn't tell me that. OK. So we got 10 minutes. That's it.
你要把我们放在一起做一个故事？你没告诉我那个。好的。所以我们有10分钟。就这样。
Can I come back to you after, if I have more questions after him?
我可以在那之后回来找你吗，如果他在那之后我有更多问题的话？
Probably not, probably not. It's no disrespect intended. I just-- yo, this is way bigger than Kessler. This is way bigger than, like, Kessler. And I normally don't even spend-- I don't give him, like, that time. I don't think you quite understand. When you give these individuals that kind of time, that legitimizes them. That's what they want is the attention.
可能不会，可能不会。没有任何不尊重。我只是——哟，这比凯斯勒大得多。这比，比如，凯斯勒大得多。我通常甚至不会花——我不给他，比如，那种时间。我不认为你完全理解。当你给这些人那种时间时，那使他们合法化了。他们想要的就是注意。
I get that. But ignoring Jason Kessler isn't going to make him go away. And I don't have the same job as Wes Bellamy. He's a politician with a political vision for Charlottesville. It makes sense for him to avoid talking about Jason Kessler. He's not going to be derailed by one guy. But I'm in Charlottesville because Jason Kessler wrote the blueprint for the rally. And at this point, he's in hiding somewhere, presumably planning something. I wanted to know what's coming and how dangerous he is. And if this story was true, that Jason Kessler's beef with this one guy motivated him to organize this rally, I wanted to understand that too.
我明白那个。但忽视杰森·凯斯勒并不会让他消失。我没有和韦斯·贝拉米一样的工作。他是一个对夏洛茨维尔有政治愿景的政客。他避免谈论杰森·凯斯勒是有道理的。他不会被一个人破坏。但我在夏洛茨维尔因为杰森·凯斯勒写了集会的蓝图。在这一点上，他躲在某个地方，大概在计划什么。我想知道什么要来了，以及他有多危险。如果这个故事是真的，杰森·凯斯勒对这个人的不满促使他组织了这次集会，我也想理解那个。
Before I spoke to Kessler, I went back and forth on telling him I'm black. I really chewed on it, wondered what was more honest. Tell him or don't tell him? Maybe he'll look me up. Maybe he'll ask me. I didn't know. It'll come up, I thought. And I don't usually start interviews with "hi, I'm black Robyn from This American Life." So I didn't do it with this one either.
在和凯斯勒谈话之前，我反复权衡是否要告诉他我是黑人。我真的咀嚼了它，想知道什么更诚实。告诉他还是不告诉他？也许他会查我。也许他会问我。我不知道。我觉得它会出现。而且我通常不以“嗨，我是来自《美国生活》的黑人罗宾”开始采访。所以我这次也没这样做。
I've been reading that you're in hiding.
我一直在读你在躲藏。
Well, I'm not announcing where I'm at. [CHUCKLING] I mean, when you have a government which won't protect you, you know, from mob violence, you can't just announce where you're going to be every moment.
好吧，我不宣布我在哪。（轻笑）我的意思是，当你有一个不会保护你的政府，你知道，免受暴民暴力，你不能只在每一刻宣布你要去哪里。
Are you saying you've been getting threats?
你是说你一直受到威胁吗？
Yeah, I've been getting constant death threats, constant lewd stuff, constant, you know, abuse from people.
是的，我一直受到不断的死亡威胁，不断的淫秽的东西，不断的，你知道，来自人们的虐待。
I wanted to ask him about Wes Bellamy, but we got on the phone and he just started going. He talked for 40 minutes, mostly about how he did have a plan for the rally, but it was thwarted by the state of emergency.
我想问他关于韦斯·贝拉米的事，但我们通话，他就直接开始了。他谈了40分钟，主要谈论他确实有一个集会计划，但它被紧急状态破坏了。
--the Constitution does not apply to me.
——宪法不适用于我。
His First Amendment right to free speech was violated. There was a lot of First Amendment talk.
他支持言论自由的第一修正案权利被侵犯了。有很多关于第一修正案的谈话。
Our First Amendment rights--
我们的第一修正案权利——
He was rambly and excitable, and he talked over me a lot. And when I finally got to ask him about Wes Bellamy and that quote, he was even more hopped up. Bellamy is against him, but it's not just Bellamy. It goes all the way up to the highest levels of Virginia government.
他语无伦次且易怒，他经常打断我的话。当我终于问他关于韦斯·贝拉米和那个引述时，他更加兴奋了。贝拉米反对他，但不仅仅是贝拉米。这一直上达弗吉尼亚政府的最高层。
I don't believe that it was the police that were trying to mess up the rally. I think that it was--
我不相信是警察试图搞乱集会。我认为是——
You don't?
你不相信？
--government officials, including mayor Mike Signer, Vice Mayor Wes Bellamy, and Virginia Governor Terry McAuliffe.
——政府官员，包括市长迈克·辛格尔（Mike Signer），副市长韦斯·贝拉米，和弗吉尼亚州州长特里·麦考利夫（Terry McAuliffe）。
I asked him more questions about Wes Bellamy until it became clear-- there wasn't much there. Kessler's resentment of the vice mayor didn't prompt him to organize the rally. That's just something he said. But we did talk about the rally, and his plans and expectations, which eventually led to something that was new to me, something specific about his beliefs that felt important to know.
我问了他更多关于韦斯·贝拉米的问题，直到很清楚——那里没什么东西。凯斯勒对副市长的怨恨并没有促使他组织集会。那只是他说的东西。但我们确实谈论了集会，以及他的计划和期望，这最终导致了我不知道的事情，关于他的信仰的特定事情，觉得有必要知道。
When President Trump stood before the press after the weekend in Charlottesville, he said not everyone at the rally was a neo-Nazi. Not everyone was a white supremacist.
当特朗普总统在夏洛茨维尔周末之后站在媒体面前时，他说不是集会上的每个人都是新纳粹。不是每个人都是白人至上主义者。
Believe me, Not all of those people were white supremacists.
相信我，那些人并非全都是白人至上主义者。
But even the guys who don't call themselves white supremacists believe all sorts of things that sound very close to or exactly the same as white supremacy. Jason, for instance, explained to me he's not a white supremacist. He's pro-white, fighting for white rights. And he organized one of the largest gatherings of white supremacists in recent memory. And he said things to me like, "each race has something to be proud of. Black people's thing being--" mhm-- "basketball."
但即使是那些不称自己为白人至上主义者的人，也相信各种听起来非常接近或完全等同于白人至上主义的事情。例如，杰森向我解释他不是白人至上主义者。他是亲白人的，为白人权利而战。他组织了最近记忆中最大的白人至上主义者集会之一。他对我说了一些话，比如，“每个种族都有值得骄傲的东西。黑人的东西是——”嗯——“篮球。”
Were you on Friday night, on the Friday night before, were you out with that crowd marching, the guys with the torches?
你在周五晚上，在那之前的周五晚上，你和那个人群游行了吗，那些举着火把的家伙？
Yes.
是的。
You were marching with them?
你和他们一起游行了？
Uh-huh.
嗯。
And that was, like, a good representation of the group who you wanted at the rally the next day?
那是，比如，你第二天想要在集会上看到的那种群体的良好代表吗？
Well, not all of it. I mean, there are elements of the online community which are into edgy humor. And I would say that some of the chants and stuff that they did were a little bit-- were in bad taste.
好吧，不是全部。我的意思是，网络社区中有喜欢前卫幽默的元素。我想说他们喊的一些口号之类的东西有点——品味很差。
Yeah, what was the edgy humor?
是的，前卫幽默是什么？
Well, I think when people say "Jews will not replace us," I think that they're taking an unhappiness with the disproportionate influence and power of Jewish people at the elite levels of power in American society. They're vastly overrepresented.
好吧，我认为当人们说“犹太人不会取代我们”时，我认为他们是对犹太人在美国社会精英阶层中不成比例的影响力和权力感到不满。他们被严重高估了。
So when the media was reporting that people with white nationalist or white supremacist symbology were carrying torches and shouting "Jews will not replace us," you were thinking, "the media's getting it wrong because they're just-- it's a joke."
所以当媒体报道说有白人民族主义或白人至上主义符号的人举着火把喊“犹太人不会取代我们”时，你就在想，“媒体搞错了，因为他们只是——这只是个笑话。”
What is the principle on which you oppose using torches? It was a form of protest. It was legal. It was permitted by free speech. And it is a good optic. It looks interesting at night.
你反对使用火把的原则是什么？这是一种抗议形式。这是合法的。它是被言论自由允许的。而且这是一个好的视觉效果。它在晚上看起来很有趣。
Kessler's a UVA grad. He's 33. He voted for Obama. And when he talks about what set him down this path to pro-white activism, he points to a single experience. I was surprised what a common experience it was, something that happens to people all the time, and they do not end up organizing rallies with torches. He didn't get a job he wanted. Here's what happened.
凯斯勒是弗吉尼亚大学的毕业生。他33岁。他投了奥巴马的票。当他谈论是什么让他走上这条亲白人激进主义的道路时，他指向了一个单一的经历。我惊讶于这是一种多么普遍的经历，这种事情人们一直都在发生，而他们并没有最终组织举着火把的集会。他没得到他想要的工作。这是发生了什么。
He didn't come from money. His parents didn't go to college. He graduated with a psych degree and student loans, and started looking for a job. He says he'd been working some. Says for about a year he was a counselor in a mental health facility.
他不是来自有钱人家。他的父母没上过大学。他毕业于心理学学位和学生贷款，开始找工作。他说他一直工作了一些。说是大约一年他是一个心理健康机构的咨询师。
So I had experience, and I tried to apply for a job at Region 10, which is the health care provider around here.
所以我有了经验，我试着申请Region 10的工作，那是这里周围的医疗服务提供者。
Mhm.
嗯。
And there were two positions. There was one position, which was full time, and one which was as-needed.
有两个职位。有一个职位，是全职，还有一个是按需的。
The full-time job went to someone else.
全职工作给了别人。
So they hired me for the as-needed thing. And I was happy about that at first, because I'd been applying for these jobs for years after I graduated, and they wouldn't even give me interviews. So when I showed up to the orientation, I met the woman who had been hired over me, you know, for the full-time position. And we were all talking in this big orientation session about our experience.
所以他们雇佣我做了按需的工作。起初我很开心，因为我毕业后申请这些工作很多年了，他们甚至不会给我面试。所以当我出现在入职培训时，我遇到了那个被雇佣在我之上的女人，你知道，为了全职职位。我们都在谈论关于我们经验的这个大入职培训课程。
She said that she had no experience in the mental health care field. She had worked as a dental hygienist. So at that point, I was pretty angry. Because I felt like I had been picked over for reasons not having anything to do with my qualifications, but having to do with identity variables. Why did I think this? Because most all the people working at this mental health care facility were white women or black women. I mean, there was no-- nothing else. It seemed to me like there was a discrimination that was happening there.
她说她在心理健康护理领域没有经验。她曾经做过牙科保健员。所以在那一刻，我非常生气。因为我觉得我被选中是因为与我的资历无关的原因，但与身份变量有关。为什么我认为这个？因为在这个心理健康护理机构工作的大多数人都是白人女性或黑人女性。我的意思是，没有——没有别的。在我看来，好像那里正在发生歧视。
Was the woman who was picked over you, was she white or black?
那个被选中在你之上的女人，她是白人还是黑人？
She was white. So I think-- I mean, the affirmative action stuff is not just about the race. It's also about the gender issue.
她是白人。所以我认为——我的意思是，肯定性行动的东西不仅仅是关于种族。它也是关于性别的问题。
I suggested, maybe it wasn't discrimination. Maybe the woman was a better interview, or some other thing you didn't know about. But he decided-- discrimination, something fishy, even though he admitted he didn't have proof.
我建议，也许那不是歧视。也许那个女人是一个更好的面试者，或者是你不知道的某件其他事情。但他决定——歧视，有什么鱼腥味，尽管他承认他没有证据。
OK, so you became convinced that that was, like, an injustice. And then you went on to work with her, right? How was she?
好的，所以你变得相信那是一个不公正。然后你继续和她工作，对吧？她怎么样？
No, no, I didn't work at that job, because I found out that the hours weren't what I thought they would be. It was only like five hours a week. That's not enough to do anything. And there was no health care, no benefits. So I declined. I wouldn't work a job where, you know, I was clearly more qualified than somebody but had been discriminated against because of some variable outside my control.
不，不，我没有在那份工作上工作，因为我发现工作时间不是我想的那样。那只有每周5个小时左右。做任何事情都不够。而且没有医疗，没有福利。所以我拒绝了。我不会做一份工作，你知道，我明明比别人更有资历，但却因为我控制不了的某个变量而受到歧视。
Of course, even if he were right, this is a story that happens much more often to women and people of color than white men. But years later, this is what Kessler points to as the beginning of a real shift. Slighted as a man, feeling like women and blacks get all the breaks, this story about being pushed out made sense to him, and it stuck. And this brings me to the thing I learned from this conversation. From there, he made a leap I truly can't understand, a leap from that experience back then to this conclusion.
当然，即使他是对的，这是一个比白人男性更常发生在女性和有色人种身上的故事。但多年后，这就是凯斯勒指向作为一个真正转变开始的事情。作为一个男人受到轻视，觉得女人和黑人得到了所有的突破，这个关于被排挤的故事对他有意义，并且它留下来了。这把我带到了我从这次谈话中学到的事情。从那里，他做了一个我真的无法理解的跳跃，一个从那时那种经历回到这个结论的跳跃。
We are being replaced culturally and ethnically.
我们正在被文化上和种族上取代。
You think there's, like, a government conspiracy to replace white people culturally?
你认为有一个，比如，政府阴谋来取代白人文化？
No, I didn't say it was a conspiracy. It is something that is happening. It's a genocide by replacement. That's part of the UN definition of genocide, is replacing a people. And that is what they are doing. They created policies starting with the 1965 Hart-Cellar Immigration Act, which gave--
不，我没说它是阴谋。它是正在发生的事情。它是通过取代进行的种族灭绝。那是联合国定义的种族灭绝的一部分，是取代一个民族。而那就是他们正在做的。他们创造了政策，从1965年的《哈特-塞勒移民法》（Hart-Cellar Immigration Act）开始，它给了——
The Hart-Cellar Act is the immigration policy that ended preferential treatment for certain European countries. It got rid of the old policy, which favored white immigrants. He's wrong, by the way, about the UN definition of genocide. It's not replacement. Genocide, according to the UN, is violent. It's the physical destruction of a people. But the way Kessler sees it, there's a genocide of white people, because America allows immigrants from countries all over the world.
《哈特-塞勒法》是结束某些欧洲国家优待待遇的移民政策。它摆脱了旧的政策，即偏袒白人移民。顺便说一句，关于联合国种族灭绝的定义，他是错的。这不是取代。种族灭绝，根据联合国，是暴力的。它是对一个民族的肉体毁灭。但以凯斯勒的方式看，有一个白人种族灭绝，因为美国允许来自世界各地的移民。
This kind of thing doesn't happen in Africa, or Latin America, or Asia. It's only in the white countries.
这种事情在非洲，或拉丁美洲，或亚洲不会发生。它只在白人国家。
I don't consider America a white country?
我不认为美国是一个白人国家？
Why wouldn't you? It's been traditionally 80% to 85% white. Our first immigration policy, you know, said that in order to be a citizen you had to be a white person of good character, right? So it was explicitly a white country. Like, there are traditional demographics. And when you don't respect those, you destroy a people.
你为什么不这样认为？它传统上80%到85%是白人。我们的第一个移民政策，你知道，说了为了成为公民你必须是一个品行良好的白人，对吧？所以它明确是一个白人国家。像，有传统的人口统计。而当你尊重那些时，你摧毁了一个民族。
"Destroy a people," "genocide." I'd never heard that before. I couldn't have guessed it. This is the new thing I learned from this conversation. But apparently this is something lots of these groups believe in. It came up 2 and 1/2 hours in, and it kind of washed past me when it happened. But later I'd mention it almost immediately to every person I talked to about him. The man who organized the rally in Charlottesville believes there's a genocide of white people in America.
“摧毁一个民族”，“种族灭绝”。我以前从未听说过。我无法猜到。这是我从这次谈话中学到的新东西。但显然这是很多这些团体相信的事情。它在2个半小时内出现，当它发生时，它有点像从我身边洗过。但后来我会几乎立即向我谈论他的每一个人提到它。夏洛茨维尔集会的组织者相信在美国有白人种族灭绝。
White civil rights, discrimination against white people, white oppression-- Kessler is constantly stealing the language of the truly disenfranchised to talk about his feelings of white disenfranchisement. He calls people racist all the time. He calls Wes Bellamy a black supremacist. He calls me a racist toward white people. I have no idea if he knew I'm black, by the way.
白人公民权利，对白人的歧视，白人压迫——凯斯勒一直在窃取真正被剥夺权利者的语言来谈论他关于白人被剥夺权利的感觉。他一直称人们为种族主义者。他称韦斯·贝拉米为黑人至上主义者。他称我为对白人有种族歧视。顺便说一句，我不知道他是否知道我是黑人。
That language is designed to have power. It took black Americans centuries to exact, black people who needed to communicate a message for our own survival, that we are not partial people, we are not a threat, we are not marginal, we are not invisible. We're people. Those words have power, the words Jason has co-opted. And they get results. I bet they'll get results for his movement too.
那种语言旨在拥有力量。黑人美国人花了几个世纪才精确化，黑人需要为我们自己的生存传达一个信息，我们不是部分的人，我们不是威胁，我们不是边缘，我们不是隐形的。我们是人。那些词拥有力量，杰森盗用的词。而且它们得到了结果。我打赌它们也会为他的运动得到结果。
We talked for four hours in two conversations. Jason Kessler says he's not a white supremacist, but he believes in white genocide. And that's just as terrifying, because it takes you to the exact same place. Namely, taking back what's yours. I told Jason as much.
我们在两次谈话中谈了四个小时。杰森·凯斯勒说他不是白人至上主义者，但他相信白人种族灭绝。而那同样可怕，因为它带你去了完全相同的地方。即，拿回属于你的东西。我告诉杰森了。
The reason that it's scary is that I don't think that even you are sure how far in over your head you are. And you're kind of being coy about-- like, you know the definition of a white supremacist, but you're not totally separating yourself from white supremacy.
它很可怕的原因是，我不认为连你自己都确定你陷得有多深。而且你有点在关于——比如，你知道白人至上主义者的定义，但你并没有完全把自己从白人至上主义中分离出来。
Was Heather Heyer completely innocent?
希瑟·海耶（Heather Heyer）是完全无辜的吗？
And white supremacy has a history of murder and killing.
而白人至上主义有谋杀和杀戮的历史。
White supremacy, blah, blah, blah. That's a BS liberal term that you have been indoctrinated with. That "white supremacy, white supremacy!" This is our country!
白人至上主义，blah，blah，blah。那是你被灌输的一个胡说八道的自由派术语。那个“白人至上主义，白人至上主义！”这是我们的国家！
After talking to Jason Kessler suddenly this past year in America looked different to me. I thought for lots of people "Make America Great Again" and white attachment to Confederate symbols was about white power, white people trying to maintain their power. Just a way of saying "remember the hierarchy. Don't forget who's on top." But Jason Kessler is a guy who does not believe he has power, and he wants it. Which is frightening, because it's unclear what he'll do to get it.
在与杰森·凯斯勒谈话后，美国过去这一年突然在我看来变得不同了。我以为对很多人来说，“让美国再次伟大”和白人对联盟符号的依恋是关于白人权力，白人试图维持他们的权力。只是说“记住等级制度。不要忘记谁在上面”的一种方式。但杰森·凯斯勒是一个不相信自己有权力的人，他想要它。这很可怕，因为不清楚为了得到它他会做什么。
He's tweeted about a coming civil war and being one of the first to go. There was one question that I wanted to ask Kessler that I never got to, because he cut the conversation short. So I called him back one more time to try and ask him.
他发推文关于即将到来的内战并成为第一批走的人。我有一个想要问凯斯勒的问题，我从来没能问，因为他提前结束了谈话。所以我再次给他打了电话试着问他。
At the tone, please record your message. When you've finished recording, you may hang up or press one for more options.
在提示音后，请记录你的信息。当你录完音后，你可以挂断或按一获取更多选项。
[BEEP]
（嘟声）
Hey, Jason. It's Robyn. I didn't get to ask you what you wanted, what your movement was looking for in the future. Is what you're hoping for a civil war, like a race war? OK, let me know. Bye.
嘿，杰森。我是罗宾。我没能问你想要什么，你的运动未来在寻找什么。你所希望的是内战，像种族战争吗？好的，让我知道。再见。
[CLICK]
（点击）
He didn't call me back. When I sent an email following up this week, asking, "Do you want a race war? What will that look like?" He responded, quote, "Ridiculous. Just run what you have. I'm not a cartoon villain." I never thought he was.
他没回我电话。当我本周发电子邮件跟进时，问，“你想要种族战争吗？那会是什么样子？”他回应，引用，“荒谬。只管运行你拥有的东西。我不是卡通反派。”我从来没认为他是。
Robyn Semien is one of the producers of our show.
罗宾·塞米恩是我们节目的制作人之一。
Our program was produced today by our senior producer, Brian Reed. People who put our show together include Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Stephanie Foo, Michele Harris, Kimberly Henderson, Chana Joffe-Walt, Mariya Karimjiee, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, BA Parker, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由我们的资深制作人布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）制作。把我们节目放在一起的人包括艾尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker），艾莉丝·伯格森（Elise Bergerson），苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton），佐伊·蔡斯，达纳·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis），斯蒂芬妮·福（Stephanie Foo），米歇尔·哈里斯（Michele Harris），金伯利·亨德森（Kimberly Henderson），查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt），玛丽亚·卡里姆吉（Mariya Karimjiee），戴维·克斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum），塞斯·林德（Seth Lind），米基·米克（Miki Meek），乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar），BA帕克（BA Parker），罗宾·塞米恩，克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala），马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney），南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike），朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker），和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he just finished learning to speak Japanese. He picked up the language in just three months, because of all the spare time he had. So much spare time. You know why?
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，他刚刚学会说日语。他只用了三个月就学会了这门语言，因为他有所有的业余时间。那么多业余时间。你知道为什么吗？
I decided not to watch porn anymore.
我决定不再看色情片了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。